facio pour un certain nombre de personnes n'a rien
à voir avec l'énergie peut signifier quelque
chose sans ammonite de parfum quoi que ce soit pour moi
Fasil se rapporte bien sûr à l'énergie, donc je suis
désolé de vouloir trouver un
équivalent chinois de ce type britannique que je n'ai pas
réussi à  faites-le, mais cette personne est
généralement dans n'importe quel pays le professeur le plus connu
chaque fois qu'il passe à la télévision et
chaque fois qu'il pose une question, vous avez
quelques millions de personnes et probablement en
Chine plusieurs dizaines de millions de personnes qui
connaissent la réponse par la suite
généralement lorsque cette personne pose un
question vous avez quatre choix vous les
connaissez à l'avance donc c'est facile vous appelez un
ami n'importe quoi pour voir 250 et passer à
l'étape suivante il n'a bien sûr jamais posé
la question comme je vais le faire
supposons que je prends quelqu'un au hasard dans
cette pièce et demander selon vous
quelle est l'énergie
dans la plupart des pays je sais que la réponse que
j'obtiendrai est l'énergie est une facture l'énergie est
quelque chose que je paie c'est trop cher
c'est toujours trop cher donc c'est mon
élé  ctricité ou facture d'essence, certaines personnes
pourraient penser que c'est ma facture d'essence,
bien qu'il n'y en ait pas beaucoup, donc fondamentalement,
et si vous demandez à un dirigeant d'une
entreprise, je peux vous assurer que la
première chose à laquelle il
répondra est que c'est une bière  vous pourriez poser la
même question à certaines personnes qui travaillent
dans le secteur de l'environnement et généralement
leur première réponse est que l'énergie signifie que les
économies ne signifient pas une facture, cela signifie des
économies, donc l'énergie est quelque chose que vous
devez dire pourquoi comment ce qui est de l'énergie
est d'ailleurs  pas la question principale il faut la
sauvegarder et puis j'ai compris qu'en
chinois c'est délicat parce que ce n'est
pas le même mot tu peux poser un point
et le poète te dira que l'énergie
c'est quelque chose qui rend la vie belle
parce que quand tu as  le matin
que tu as fait le plein d'énergie alors
tu es d'humeur à faire absolument
n'importe quoi de bien il arrive que les deux
premières réponses soient fausses et que la dernière
réponse soit juste car effectivement l'énergie c'est
par définition ce qui change  L'
énergie du monde est en physique comme vous vous en souvenez peut-être
pour certains l'unité qui
est vous d'autres le contact qui sert
à caractériser le fait que le
monde change et pour être plus précis l'
énergie caractérise le changement d'état
d'un système entre deux  étapes plus
le système a changé avant et
après plus d'énergie a été impliquée
plus vous avez d'énergie plus le monde
va changer par définition en physique
c'est à peu près aussi simple que ça Je
vais maintenant illustrer ce que je viens de dire
avec quelques exemples tirés de
la vie courante chaque fois que vous modifiez la
température d'une pièce, par exemple, vous
avez de l'énergie impliquée pour la refroidir ou
pour la guérir chaque fois que vous avez un objet
qui change de vitesse, vous avez de l'énergie
impliquée essence pour une voiture kérosène pour
avion  mazout lourd pour bateau désolé
électricité pour un métier quel qu'il soit quand
vous avez une forme qui change vous avez de l'
énergie en jeu en fait la première forme
que vous changez tout le temps est celle de
vos membres lorsque vous changez la forme de
votre bras vous avez besoin d'énergie qui fait partie
de l'énergie contenue dans la
nourriture que vous avez mangée la plupart de l'énergie sera
utilisée pour chauffer votre corps et une petite partie
sera utilisée pour réfléchir un peu  partie
et un peu mais sera également utilisé pour bien
bouger vos jambes chaque fois que vous avez dans
l'industrie une machine qui change
la forme de tout ce dont elle a besoin d'énergie
pour fonctionner
vous avez également de l'énergie qui est impliquée
lorsque vous modifiez une composition chimique
vous avez de l'énergie  qui est impliqué
lorsqu'un objet qui interagit avec le champ
se déplace dans le champ donné et par
exemple lorsque votre corps interagit qui
interagit avec le champ gravitationnel
se déplace dans ce champ par exemple
vous montez un escalier
vous savez certainement qu'il y a de l'énergie
dans ou quand vous avez une
composition atomique qui change, vous avez de l'énergie
impliquée et en fait vous remarquerez peut-être
que toute l'énergie est que l'humanité
utilise notre télécommande ou ferme ses événements de
l'énergie nucléaire absolument toutes les
énergies que nous utilisons sont des dérivés de
l'énergie nucléaire et lorsque vous interagissez
avec le rayonnement,
vous avez également de l'énergie impliquée et la plupart je
dirai que les nouvelles les plus courantes de cette
interaction sont un four à micro-ondes par
exemple ou dans un laser industriel
c'est la belle  version qui peut se produire à
nouveau dans le Soleil le caractère énergétique caractérise le
changement donc chaque fois que vous
comptez l'énergie, vous ne pouvez pas changer chaque fois que
vous devez changer vous avez de l'énergie vous
ne pouvez tout simplement pas éviter de changer le monde
lorsque vous utilisez de l'énergie et compte tenu de cette
caractéristique de l'énergie quelque chose
comme  l'énergie propre n'existe pas car, comme
vous le savez peut-être, être propre, c'est
ne rien toucher lorsque vous utilisez de l'énergie, par
définition, quelque chose change et la plupart
du temps, vous réalisez que l'énergie propre entre
guillemets est en fait une énergie qui
est utilisée en quantité si ridicule
qu'entre autres choses  les effets négatifs ne
peuvent pas être très importants une
énergie propre lorsqu'elle est utilisée en très petite quantité
cesse généralement d'être  nettoyez quand vous l'
utilisez ou quand vous l'appelez avec des
sommes énormes parlons d'argent je suis désolé je
vais utiliser les salaires occidentaux mais je veux dire
même si vous enlevez un zéro pour ce que je
vais vous expliquer vous comprendrez toujours
ce que je dis si vous prenez
quelque chose qui est proche du je
dirais le salaire minimum ou ouais le salaire minimum en
Europe vous paierez votre kilowattheure en
supposant que vous ne vous intéressez qu'au
travail physique quelque chose entre 200
et 2 000 euros il suffit de multiplier  que d'ici 10
pour avoir des UN globalement d'
accord donc tu paieras ton kilowattheure
20 000 us quand la machine utilisant du pétrole
pourra te rendre le même
service pour une fraction d'euro ou
plusieurs US donc quand on passe d'homme à
machine ça veut dire  qu'on peut obtenir la
même transformation de l'environnement
pour plusieurs centaines à plusieurs milliers de
fois moins d'argent tout ce qui a permis à
notre civilisation industrielle se trouve là
absolument tout cela a été à l'origine
de l'augmentation de la productivité de
travail cela a été à l'origine de l'
émergence des pays émergents cela a
été à l'origine de la superpuissance
qui s'appelle les États-Unis cela
a été à l'origine de votre vie 70
ans au lieu de 20 cela a été à l'
origine de  un appartement pour une famille une voiture
pour une famille parmi les classes moyennes etc
cela a été à l'origine de tout ce
que vous savez dans le monde moderne absolument
tout car vous savez si nous n'avons pas eu de pétrole
gaz charbon et plus marginalement cascades
uranium et ainsi de suite  et donc nous vivrions toujours en
tant que paysans du Moyen Âge
maintenant je vais dire quelque chose qui est
très politiquement incorrect et je
m'excuse d'avance mais je vais quand même le
dire supposons que vous preniez un esclave
comme vous le savez probablement  un esclave n'est pas
quelqu'un qui a
voulu devenir esclave ce n'est
généralement pas quelque chose que vous souhaitez faire
lorsque vous êtes à l'école pour devenir esclave
uniquement pour une très petite fraction de la
population que je ne mentionnerai pas
donc si vous êtes  un esclave il y a des chances que
quelqu'un soit venu vous chercher
contre vous cela coute de l'argent alors
vous devez être nourri protégé contre
trop de chaleur trop de froid maladie etc
sinon le mec qui vous possède
perdants est bien un ensemble si vous empilez  tout
l'argent nécessaire pour acheter un
esclave et le maintenir en vie le
maintient désolé dans la vie et vous
arriverez à la conclusion qu'avoir un
kilowattheure mécanique d'un esclave est
toujours quelque chose qui est de dix à douze
cents tonnes désolées
cher que l'utilisation d'une machine et la
raison pour laquelle l'esclavage a pratiquement
disparu de la Terre n'est pas parce que
le code génétique de l'humanité a changé
nous avons exactement le même code génétique que
nos ancêtres il y a huit générations c'est
juste parce qu'il est devenu économiquement
sans aucun sens à utiliser  des gens qui
pourraient se révolter qui doivent dormir qui
doivent manger et qui pourraient s'échapper alors que
la machine qui ne fait rien de tout cela
peut faire le même travail pour 100 fois moins d'
argent donc e  l'énergie a libéré des esclaves
essentiellement comme vous le savez probablement les
physiciens ont une habitude très ennuyeuse
d'utiliser des lois que vous ne pouvez pas
violer Je vais maintenant utiliser une loi
qui ne peut pas être violée même si nous
aimerions quelle est la loi de
conservation qui s'applique  à l'énergie et
cette loi de conservation dit qu'une
chose très simple est que dans un système fermé, l'
énergie ne peut ni être créée ni être
détruite, donc quand vous regardez le
système fermé qui ne le communique
pas avec le reste du monde, la quantité
de  l'énergie dans le système est constante
et il ne peut y avoir autre chose
qui signifie quelque chose de très simple pour l'
humanité cela signifie désolé cela signifie que l'
humanité ne peut faire qu'une chose quand il
s'agit d'énergie en obtenir dans l'
environnement où elle existe déjà et l'
utiliser si nous  n'avons pas d'énergie dans
l'environnement nous ne pouvons pas avoir d'énergie nous
ne pouvons pas la créer comme Harry Potter avec
une baguette magique nous devons utiliser quelque chose
qui existe déjà dans l'
énergie de l'environnement  qui existe déjà dans l'
environnement s'appelle l'énergie primaire peut
être du pétrole du gaz du charbon de l'uranium des cascades du bois des
rayons de soleil des ailes etc ces énergies sont
toujours gratuites pas parce que je le veux
parce que c'est le cas la formation d'
énergie dans l'environnement est gratuite personne
dans cette pièce non  un dans l'humanité a payé un
seul centime ou un seul yuan ou un seul
ce que vous voulez pour que l'énergie existe
l'énergie existait avant le lamantin
c'est là nous n'avons qu'à aller l'obtenir
toutes les ressources naturelles en fait
gratuites personne n'a payé un seul centime dans cette
pièce pour  les ressources naturelles existent d'accord
ils sont tous gratuits
c'est très courant chez les écologistes de dire
que le vent et le soleil sont gratuits c'est vrai
mais le pétrole est gratuit le coke est gratuit et le gaz est
gratuit tout ce qu'il faut c'est du travail humain pour aller le
chercher et le  les loyers qu'il faut
payer aux particuliers qui ont la
bonne idée de s'asseoir dessus mais
c'est tout ce que vous payez vous ne payez pas la
formation d'énergie vous payez le fait
que vous accédez à l'énergie et c'est
seuls les revenus humains car tout ce que vous payez est le
travail pour obtenir de l'énergie il se trouve
que plus l'énergie que vous pouvez
trouver dans l'environnement est concentrée
facile à extraire facile à transporter facile à
stocker moins elle sera chère et c'est
la raison pour laquelle  les combustibles fossiles tant que
nous en aurons 20 resteront pour toujours
moins chers que les énergies renouvelables de New York pour toujours
ce n'est pas une question de volonté politique
lobby industriel quoi que ce soit une question
de physique c'est une question de physique et en
fait c'est à cause de cette
caractéristique que quand vous regardez  l'
histoire de l'humanité nous ne sommes pas passés des
combustibles fossiles aux énergies renouvelables nous sommes passés des
énergies renouvelables aux combustibles fossiles le premier
bateau était propulsé par le
vent  le charbon
et le gaz sont tellement plus
pratiques que les énergies renouvelables que nous
avons abandonné les énergies renouvelables d'abord les combustibles fossiles
après ceci est un calcul simple
pour illustrer ce que j'ai jus  Je n'ai pas dit qu'il suffit de
prendre un cube qui a une dimension de 10
mètres de chaque côté supposons que c'est de l'
air donc c'est du vent supposons qu'il souffle
à 80 kilomètres à l'heure, ce qui est un
assez bon vent, je peux vous dire que
quand vous avez ce vent et quand  vous
naviguez, vous feriez mieux de chercher Harbour et
et reste l'honneur bien le
contenu énergétique de cette affaire de gros cube se déplaçant
à cette vitesse est le même une fois qu'il est passé
par un moulin à vent que le
contenu énergétique de trois millilitres d'huile je
vous demande  la question qu'est-ce que vous pensez
est le plus pratique pour extraire de
l'environnement mon affaire de cube qui avance
vite sur la gauche sont trois millilitres
d'huile sur la droite bien sûr c'est
anodin comme une feuille sur la droite c'est
pourquoi le coût technique de l'extraction  le pétrole
dans les déserts du moyen-orient c'est une fraction
de centime par kilowattheure une fraction de
centime d'Europe c'est ridicule à cause
de cette énergie on a pu mettre
au travail nos esclaves modernes qui sont des
machines un tracteur par exemple  est l'
équivalent de 600 paires de jambes compte tenu de
la puissance d'un tracteur moyen et c'est à
peu près l'équivalent de la
puissance moyenne d'une voiture, donc si vous vouliez que des
gens tirent votre voiture pour que la voiture
aille à la même vitesse qu'elle va avec
le moteur il faudrait plusieurs
centaines de personnes à vélo devant la
voiture cet engin de travaux publics fait
le même boulot que plusieurs milliers de paires
de bras si les techniques de construction
et les engins et si l'énergie n'était pas au
courant aujourd'hui était la même que celles que
nous avons  utilisé lorsque nous construisons des pyramides il
ne faudrait pas quelques mois pour ériger une nouvelle
tour à Shanghai il faudrait un
siècle mais vous pouvez voir sur ce graphique
que jusqu'au début du 20ème
siècle le code fourni par habitant
augmente puis reste constant pour  environ
un siècle et depuis une décennie ou une
décennie et demie a de nouveau augmenté c'est
entièrement l'effet de la montée de la
Chine c'est totalement dû à la Chine essentiellement
dans le reste du monde le code
contre  La consommation par habitant diminue plus ou moins
ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est que la
consommation de pétrole par habitant
n'a pas remplacé la consommation de base est
passée au-dessus puis au-dessus de : pétrole vous obtenez
gaz hydro nucléaire biomasse et cette toute
petite chose est l'agrégat de  de nouvelles
énergies renouvelables par habitant donc c'est l'
agrégat de l'éolien photovoltaïque par le gaz au
thermique etc pourquoi est-ce que le charbon a
augmenté puis est resté constant c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui et que vous savez très
bien en Chine le charbon est le premier moyen de
produire de l'électricité dans le monde et  la
production d'électricité a augmenté très
très vite au cours du dernier demi-siècle le
pétrole n'alimente pas les mêmes machines le
pétrole alimente des machines qui servent à se
déplacer alors que le charbon sert à alimenter des
machines qui produisent de l'électricité et nous
ne nous déplaçons pas avec l'électricité avec laquelle nous nous déplaçons
le pétrole alimente 98% de tous
les bateaux voitures camions qui sont des puces
qui se déplacent dans le monde entier, donc le pétrole
biaise l'énergie du commerce et la
bioessence l'énergie du mouvement ga  s
est arrivé en haut, etc., comme vous pouvez le
voir clairement sur ce graphique jusqu'à ce que l'huile choque
quelque chose qui devrait sonner une cloche pour
tous ceux dans cette pièce qui ont les
cheveux blancs comme moi vous souvenez-vous de quel
short oui je fais d'autres personnes sont
le  d'autres vous êtes probablement trop jeune alors
peut-être avez-vous appris les chocs pétroliers dans les
livres d'histoire mais sinon vous n'avez pas bien
vu le public les
chocs pétroliers étaient quelque chose que beaucoup de gens
dans les pays occidentaux au moins ont
interprété comme le prix du pétrole monte
puis ça redescend puis on en a fini
avec le problème en fait on n'en a
pas du tout fini avec les problèmes le
choc pétrolier correspond à un moment de l'
histoire où l'approvisionnement en énergie s'est arrêté de
croître l'approvisionnement en énergie désolé par habitant a
cessé de croître surtout avant  les chocs pétroliers,
l'énergie fournie par
habitant augmentait au taux moyen de 2,5
% par an,
cela signifie qu'on nous donne la définition de l'
énergie selon laquelle chaque année, vous obtenez 2,5
% de flottement physique supplémentaire qui  est
stable des chaises fabriquées des
voitures fabriquées des verres des
bâtiments quel que soit leur nom cela
signifie qu'avec de plus en plus d'énergie chaque
individu est capable de maîtriser plus de
machines et donc de produire par
individu plus de bien c'est l'
augmentation très rapide de la production et donc de la
consommation qui a été  connu par
le monde occidental pendant l'après-guerre
avant la guerre assez d'années après que la
terre ait abattu l'énergie l'approvisionnement en pétrole par
habitant commence à diminuer et donc
l'approvisionnement en énergie par habitant reste
constant cet effet des dix dernières
années est en fait entièrement dû à la Chine  et
si vous prenez les pays de l'OCDE, l'
approvisionnement énergétique par habitant est resté
constant depuis le choc pétrolier, il a en
fait commencé à diminuer depuis 2006 et j'y
reviendrai plus tard
encore, nous avons atteint aujourd'hui un
niveau de consommation d'énergie sans précédent
et nous avons donc
exigé  pour de vrais super pouvoirs qui ont
fait de nous des Superman pour de vrai si l'énergie
n'existait pas pour avoir  le même
niveau de vie moyen, bien sûr, c'est très
inégal, mais pour avoir le même niveau de
vie que nous avons sur terre à sept ans
et quelque chose de milliards d'êtres humains, nous
aurions besoin d'une autre planète dans le
système solaire avec 1 400 milliards d'hommes
dessus faisant du vélo Oldale et  nous envoyer l'énergie
d'accord c'est ce qu'il faudrait
pour obtenir le même niveau de vie si nous
n'avions pas d'énergie ou une autre façon
de dire c'est que l'énergie fournit à
chaque être humain l'équivalent de 200
esclaves 24 heures sur 24 tous vos  rap pour
rien pour rien
c'est ce qu'est l'énergie maintenant j'espère que vous
commencez à comprendre pourquoi il va être
si difficile d'amener la population à s'en
passer et maintenant j'espère que vous commencez à
comprendre pourquoi les pourparlers sur le climat ne sont pas
juste une formalité que nous avons
traverser avant d'avoir un monde magique,
donc notre système économique complet est fondamentalement
un moyen gigantesque de
transformer les ressources naturelles
afin de faire autre chose qui a
plus de valeur à nos yeux que  s
est ce qu'est notre système économique et la
transformation des ressources comme je l'ai dit est par
définition de l'énergie car la transformation
c'est de l'énergie et cette énergie qui permet
de transporter des ressources naturelles est large
pour un par nos muscles et pour 200 par des
machines à énergie et maintenant vous commencez
à comprendre  si on n'a pas assez d'
énergie on n'aura pas assez de production
même si on a des banquiers très sympas
qui sont prêts à prêter à tout le monde et
même si on a plein d'ouvriers d'
accord et l'idée qui est communément
répandue que si on augmente le
population vous augmenterez le PIB est
faux si vous augmentez le nombre de
machines et le nombre et la quantité d'
énergie vous augmentez le PIB si vous
augmentez la population en disant non
pas de machine vous augmentez le nombre de
chômeurs c'est tout ce que vous faites d'accord
ça renverse l'équation d'une manière qui
est dérangeante je comprends mais c'est
exactement le problème que nous
vivons actuellement en occident dans le
monde occidental même chose si y  ou comme les
ressources, vous manquerez de production, dites que
si vous aimez pêcher, vous n'aurez
pas de PIB pour la pêche, évidemment avec le
rapport de 1 à 100, vous vous attendez à ce que le
PIB mondial évolue non pas comme la
population mondiale mais comme l'
approvisionnement énergétique mondial  eh bien c'est exactement ce qu'il
fait c'est le meilleur modèle macroéconomique
au monde que je connaisse c'est une
ligne droite et il vous donne sur l'
axe horizontal depuis 1965 l'approvisionnement énergétique dans le
monde et sur l'axe vertical le
PIB mondial en dollars constants bien  ce que
vous voyez c'est que vous donnez l'énergie vous donnez
le PIB c'est très simple c'est extrêmement
simple et c'est extrêmement logique vu
ce que j'ai dit c'est vrai en
chiffres absolus mais c'est aussi vrai quand on
regarde les variations annuelles sur ces deux termes
le vert vous montre le
changement d'année en année concernant l'
approvisionnement énergétique dans le monde et le terme marron
va vous dire que vous êtes sur votre
changement pour la production industrielle dans le
monde pas d'énergie pas d'industrie
vous connaissez probablement cette blague de James
Kerr souffle qui était un
économiste britannique qui a dit une fois si jamais vous rencontrez
quelqu'un qui croit que la
croissance perpétuelle est possible il est soit fou soit
économiste si je regarde l'énergie
qui rend le système industriel possible
aujourd'hui quoi  est-ce que je vais
bien je reçois surtout des combustibles fossiles les
combustibles fossiles ont deux caractéristiques la
première est que le stock initial que nous
avions quand nous avons commencé la révolution industrielle nous
a été donné une fois
pour toutes
car il faut des dizaines de millions d'
années pour se former  pétrole et gaz et il a fallu des
centaines de millions d'années pour
téléphoner donc au début du
monopole très spécial que nous jouons
aujourd'hui nous avions un stock donné de pétrole et de
gaz et nous n'en aurons pas plus donc tout ce que nous
pouvons faire c'est épuiser  le stock initial d'accord
c'est un problème je vais faire un
commentaire comique je suis cinq minutes parce que
je manque de temps je vous ai dit l'autre
chose est que comme ils sont Ford de
quelque chose de molécules qui inc  lude
carbon chaque fois que vous les brûlez, vous obtenez du
co2 et vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas éviter cette
chimie de base, donc les combustibles fossiles sont à la
base de notre pouvoir d'achat car
ils sont à la base de l'
approvisionnement énergétique du monde aujourd'hui d'ailleurs en
fait au moins les Français  presse et je
comprends que dans un certain nombre d'autres
pays quand vous regardez ce qui se
dit sur l'énergie
depuis cinq à dix ans, vous obtenez
plein d'articles sur les énergies renouvelables
plein plein plein ce que je dis souvent à
ces journalistes c'est  que je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit la première chose que nous devrions
regarder parce que quand on regarde la croissance
de l'approvisionnement énergétique au cours des 40 dernières
années, ce qui arrive sur la première marche
du podium est froid et ne gagne pas du tout
isola au cours de la dernière  quatorze ans le
charbon a monté 35 fois plus vite que le
solaire puis danse plus vite que le vent
et il se trouve que le charbon est un enjeu si
on veut lutter contre le changement climatique donc on
est maintenant à contre-courant de tous les discours qui
peuvent être
tenus  faire exactement le contraire de ce qui
devrait être fait si vous voulez être sérieux au
sujet du changement de Tommy et c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est parce que nous utilisons de plus en
plus de charbon pour produire de l'électricité,
comme vous pouvez le voir, le charbon et le gaz représentent les
deux tiers de l'électricité  généré
dans le monde aujourd'hui le pétrole a un peu
la première génération renouvelable est de loin l'
hydroélectricité aujourd'hui nous produisons
plus de 22 mille milliards de kilowattheures
d'électricité par an dans le monde
c'était 600 en 1945 600 d'accord vraiment raison
très vite juste deux petites questions une
combien de temps allons-nous obtenir un
approvisionnement toujours croissant de ces combustibles
fossiles en second lieu que se passe-t-il une fois que nous avons
mis les déchets de l'utilisation des combustibles fossiles qui
sont le co2 dans l'atmosphère ces deux
questions sont interconnectées vous ne pouvez pas
regarder l'une sans regarder l'autre
un et entre vous avez la
production de tout cela qui est le PIB
alors maintenant vous comprenez que se passer du
changement climatique signifie se passer
des combustibles fossiles et k  en guise de moyen de se
passer du PIB aurons-nous le choix la
réponse courte n'est pas une bonne nouvelle la
réponse courte est maintenant je vais commencer par
la partie en amont la partie en amont comme je l'ai
dit des accords avec l'approvisionnement en combustibles
fossiles les combustibles fossiles ont été donnés  à nous
et il y a un stock initial une
dotation initiale dans la croûte terrestre qui nous est
donnée une fois pour toutes eh bien les
mathématiques les mathématiques simples ont permis
de démontrer que dans un tel cas une
chose que vous ne pouvez pas obtenir est une offre toujours croissante au
fil du temps c'est  assez facile à
comprendre d'accord si le stock est donné
une fois pour toutes, vous ne pouvez pas vous êtes
ici et avez toujours un approvisionnement croissant
vous ne pouvez même pas que vous êtes après votre tête
pour toujours avoir un approvisionnement constant nous lisons que
vous ne pouvez même pas avoir tout cela  vous pouvez
avoir et c'est un théorème mathématique je peux même le
démontrer encore donner ma vieillesse
vous dit que lorsque vous partez du
stock initial qui est donné une fois
pour toutes si vous remontez assez loin dans le temps
l'extraction précoce sera b  e néant,
ce qui est facile à vérifier si vous allez
assez loin dans le futur,
l'extraction par an sera bien supérieure
au jeu McNeill et entre les deux, vous
aurez un maximum absolu et une
diminution de la tendance par la suite ce max n'est
pas une idéologie ce n'est pas mon  Je souhaite personnellement que
ce ne soit que des cartes, donc pour le gaz fer comme pour l'
appel comme pour le minerai de fer comme pour le cuivre comme
pour le diamant désolé mesdames comme pour l'or
désolé mesdames encore comme pour le platine comme
pour le nickel comme pour le chrome comme pour
tout ce qui vient de la croûte terrestre avec
un  dotation initiale vous aurez une
pêche à l'approvisionnement annuel nous sommes
là pour le pétrole dépend presque de ce que vous
appelez le pétrole nous sommes là pour le vrai
pétrole donc tous les poids nous y sommes
déjà pour l'or ou l'argent je ne me
souviens pas nous  sera bientôt là pour un
certain nombre d'autres minerais,
cela arrivera de toute façon, peu importe ou et
quel que soit le combustible fossile que vous regardez,
les seules bonnes questions sont quand enfin à
quelle hauteur au plus et quelles sont les
conséquences et la dernière question
concerne  le changement climatique est si nous le
désirons ou devons-nous l'attendre mais
fondamentalement nous sommes sûrs de l'avoir
concernant le pétrole nous approchons de la plage
nous approchons du bec et une façon de le
voir est de regarder le taux de croissance du
minerai  production dans le monde c'est le
taux de croissance sur un siècle et demi
avec des moyens très rudimentaires un siècle et
demi la production de pétrole augmentait de 50% par
an puis les moyens techniques
se sont sophistiqués et le
taux de croissance est descendu à 10% alors ce qui est
étonnant  en fait l'
amélioration technique est une réponse aux
difficultés croissantes et ce n'est pas le début
d'une nouvelle ère qui ne va pas dans ce sens alors nous
avions des moyens encore plus sophistiqués et
coûteux et la hausse annuelle est
descendue à 5% et après les coups de pétrole c'est
aussi presque  zéro
même si nous exploitons du pétrole de schiste et
qu'en fait, la charge est de retour vers le futur, le
gaz de schiste est connu aux États-Unis.  pendant
deux siècles d'accord, donc c'est de retour vers le
futur en tapant du violoncelle et du gaz pour enfants et
donc c'est une idée approximative de l'approvisionnement mondial en pétrole
la courbe bleue vous donne le
prédateur donc vous voyez que nous y sommes presque en
fonction des particules la plupart des gens dans
ce  le cas dira oh mon mon mon combien
vais-je payer pour le puits de pétrole
j'essaie j'essaierai d'expliquer que ce n'est
pas une question la première raison pour laquelle ce n'est
pas la question est parce que vous ne pouvez pas
deviner le prix du pétrole l'International
L'Agence de l'énergie chaque année essaie de deviner
le prix du pétrole et quand ils ont
raison c'est par accident ce que vous pouvez voir
sur cette courbe sur cette courbe rouge c'est le
prix réel du pétrole que vous êtes en Europe
et toutes les autres courbes qui représentent
le  suppositions faites par l'Agence internationale de l'
énergie et vous voyez à lire les
dernières années qui ont dit qu'il
augmenterait pour toujours et qu'il est tombé si fondamentalement
lorsque le droit au gaz est accidentel la
deuxième raison est que vous n'avez aucune
relation entre le prix et le volume en
ce qui concerne o  il sur ce graphique j'ai tracé
pour le siècle dernier le prix du pétrole
que vous obtenez ici au volume de pétrole
consommé est produit qui est le même
que vous obtenez ici si le prix et les volumes
avaient une véritable élasticité l'économie de poids
est à considérer  eh bien, plus vous
avez de pétrole, plus le prix devrait être bas
et inversement, moins vous avez de pétrole,
plus le prix devrait être élevé, donc tous
les points devraient être le long de ce type de
courbe, ce n'est pas ce que vous voyez,
vous pouvez avoir beaucoup beaucoup  plus de pétrole avec le
même prix la même quantité de pétrole avec un
prix qui vacille et fait
n'importe quoi puis encore une fois vous pouvez avoir beaucoup
plus de pétrole avec un peu de changement ou pas de
changement de prix alors plus de pétrole
avec le prix faisant tout ce que vous n'avez
pas  une chose telle qu'une élasticité-prix en volume
concernant le pétrole, vous ne l'
avez d'ailleurs pour aucun minéral ou lorsque
vous regardez des chiffres à long terme, d'accord, donc
quelque chose qui est à la base de
nombreux raisonnements de macro-économistes est
simplement de tenir
c'est très ea  sy pour démontrer il suffit de
regarder le passé vous n'avez aucun lien non plus
entre le prix du pétrole et le
PIB mondial même chose c'est le prix du
pétrole c'est le PIB mondial s'il y avait une
corrélation quand le prix du pétrole
baisse le PIB devrait  augmenter et lorsque
le prix du pétrole augmente, le PIB devrait
diminuer, ce qui n'est absolument pas ce
que vous dites ce que vous regardez
avec ce point, le PIB peut augmenter avec
le prix du pétrole augmentant sans que le prix
n'augmente sans que le prix ne diminue
sans que le prix ne diminue en notant le
les choses qui sont liées sont le PIB mondial
par habitant et le volume d'un ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphique est l'urine votre
changement c'est un changement en douceur sur trois ans
mais n'exploite pas l'année sur votre changement
de la production de pétrole et l'urine votre
changement du PIB par habitant et vous voyez
que depuis les chocs pétroliers précisément les
deux sont fortement couplés et vous voyez la
variation de notre production se produire
avant la variation du PIB par habitant
donc le meilleur signe précoce  n de la variation
du PIB par habitant que vous avez sur
terre est la variation de la
production de pétrole sur terre l'année précédente en
regardant cela vous pourriez prédire le
ralentissement chinois pas très difficile pas
très difficile
vous pouvez également prédire la
crise financière au  Pays occidentaux c'est
l'approvisionnement énergétique de la zone OCDE depuis
1965, vous pouvez voir probablement
assez surprenant pour la plupart d'entre vous que l'
approvisionnement en pétrole dans les pays de l'OCDE a culminé en 2005
parce qu'en 2005 l'approvisionnement mondial en pétrole a
commencé à plafonner, c'est-à-dire à rester
constant au fil des ans  ce qui continue d'
augmenter, ce sont d'autres choses que le pétrole
les liquides de gaz naturel les condensats mais pas le
pétrole le pétrole est constant depuis 2005 et comme
nous augmentons le nombre de consommateurs sur terre,
la zone OCDE en reçoit moins parce que le pétrole
représente une si grande partie de l'approvisionnement énergétique
de l'oacd  l'approvisionnement énergétique de la
zone ocde dans son ensemble a culminé en 2006 en
fait c'est le résultat d'une tendance qui
a commencé il y a bien plus longtemps c'est l'
année de votre changement de  l'approvisionnement énergétique
dans la zone ocde et vous voyez qu'il
augmentait que moins que moins que moins
puis est passé par zéro en tendance et maintenant
est négatif donc la perspective pour l'
approvisionnement énergétique de la zone OCDE est
qu'il va continuer à diminuer et je  got on
va retrouver une croissance perpétuelle dans la
zone OCDE je crois encore plus qu'on
est à un à deux peut être trois ans d'écart
de la prochaine crise financière grave
crise financière dans la zone OCDE
justement pour cette raison le reste
du monde a un peu plus de temps  à venir
mais fondamentalement la tendance est la
même et maintenant dans les 30 secondes qu'il
me reste si le changement climatique devait
déclencher un refroidissement de la terre de 5
degrés
je peux déjà vous donner le nombre de
morts entre 2 et 5 milliards de personnes
tous  les latitudes moyennes deviendraient
définitivement gelées et impropres à l'
agriculture et donc je peux vous dire que 2 à 5
milliards de personnes est probablement le bon
ordre de grandeur je n'ai pas la
moindre idée du possible  le
bilan d'une augmentation de 5 degrés de la
température moyenne en un siècle mais je
peux vous dire que c'est très
probablement plusieurs centaines de millions mon
pari personnel serait quelque chose de plus de 1
milliard et mon pari personnel est de plus de 1
milliard parce que cela va  arriver
en même temps que la réserve d'énergie
qui nous permet de réagir à n'importe quoi
va diminuer donc si on ne fait pas les
choses assez vite et si on ne
commence pas à faire les choses avec le bon
ordre de grandeur maintenant pas dans deux ans
maintenant  nous déclencherons une situation dans laquelle
nous aurons un problème
de plus en plus grand avec des besoins de plus en plus décroissants pour résoudre
le problème et cela signifie aussi très probablement la
guerre un peu partout
parce que quand vous regardez l'histoire, vous vous
rendez compte que les populations humaines sous
stress deviennent égoïstes et  agressif
c'est comme ça que nous sommes construits d'accord,
arrêtez parce que j'aimerais que ce soit comme ça que
nous obtenons essentiellement ce que je viens de vous dire,
c'est que l'énergie est égale au PIB lutter contre le
changement climatique de base  ly va avec la
récession nommez-le d'une autre manière si vous
voulez mais ça va être très difficile
d'éviter que les deux vont ensemble
bien sûr étant donné les habitudes que nous avons prises
depuis deux siècles personne n'est prêt à le
faire pour de vrai à moins qu'un  vous
assistez déjà à une récession sans l'
avoir choisie, ce qui est le cas de l'
Europe, puis vous êtes dos au mur
et donc éliminer progressivement les combustibles fossiles de
manière délibérée est votre meilleure option ou B,
ce qui pourrait être le cas pour la Chine, je
ne  Je ne sais pas que la pollution associée aux
combustibles fossiles est devenue si insupportable pour
les dirigeants locaux qu'ils veulent
s'en débarrasser, c'est probablement aussi une
situation dans laquelle des
choses intéressantes peuvent se produire si nous voulons nous débarrasser
des combustibles fossiles aussi vite que possible.  possible nous
avons cinq secteurs principaux dans lesquels nous
devrions agir dans les bâtiments le mot principal est l'
efficacité
cela signifie isoler contre le chaud ou le
froid évidemment ici plus contre le chaud
que contre le froid en Europe plus
contre  appelé cela contre le temps chaud,
donc cela dépend de la réglementation des transports,
la première chose la plus simple à faire est de
réduire la taille de tous les véhicules que nous utilisons, compter la
taille des voitures à la baisse cetera et favoriser le
transfert modal dans l'industrie, nous avons besoin de
beaucoup de choses bien sûr l'industrie
chaque secteur industriel a  sa propre
caractéristique, il y a donc très peu de
solutions miracles que vous pouvez appliquer à l'
ensemble du secteur industriel pris comme
quelque chose que nous choisissons combien d'énergie ce n'est
pas homogène entre autres dans
l'industrie vous avez la
production d'électricité et l'une des choses qui
est urgente est  supprimer le charbon de
la production d'électricité le plus rapidement
possible. Personnellement, je suis favorable au fait
que, dans les négociations sur le climat, tous les pays
devraient s'entendre pour supprimer ce
qui n'est pas la construction d'une seule
centrale électrique au charbon supplémentaire et tous les entre guillemets
émergents ou sous-développés ou
appelez-le comme vous voulez.  que les pays
devraient demander aux pays développés est
le moyen de produire de l'électricité sans
charbon et  d ça devrait être le chef-d'œuvre du
fonds vert qui ne devrait pas regarder
autre chose nous devrions nous concentrer là-
dessus et dans l'agriculture le problème principal
est de ne pas manger trop de boeuf
essentiellement parce que le boeuf produit du
méthane et il a besoin de beaucoup de
culture d'opportunité  pour être nourris, donc
fondamentalement, la pression la plus lourde que nous exerçons
sur l'environnement est de manger de gros
animaux et si je peux être un peu
provocateur ici, j'ai compris que la
Chine passe des petits aux gros
animaux, ce qui n'est pas une très bonne nouvelle pour
le climat mondial  mieux vaut faire l'
autre dans l'autre sens bien sûr
il y a trois façons d'être sage et de pousser
vous avez dit la première façon est de penser que c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de provoquer ce soir le temps
dira si j'ai réussi ou
échoué
il dit Confucius la meilleure façon de  sois
sage et apprends le deuxième test est d'
imiter ceux qui semblent faire les bonnes
choses le dernier qui est le
plus amer est par expérience je crois
que si on tente l'expérience de manquer de
fossile  des carburants sans l'avoir souhaité
et le changement climatique sans les moyens d'y faire
face ce sera une expérience très très amère
à la fin on se rendra compte
que ça aurait été mieux de
ne pas l'expérimenter mais ce sera trop
tard car on a gagné'  t avoir une seconde
chance le temps que l'horizon temporel du
changement climatique se situe dans la génération Y, d'accord
une fois que le changement climatique a commencé, vous ne pouvez tout simplement
pas arrêter les choses pour la génération Y à
cause de l'inertie de l'océan et
des calottes glaciaires, c'est donc une expérience que
nous ferons
une fois  pas deux fois juste une fois et la deuxième
chose que Confucius a dite est probablement une
réponse à la réaction de certains d'entre vous d'
accord si 2 degrés est trop difficile à atteindre
oublions 2 degrés ce que Confucius a
dit non si 2 degrés est trop difficile à
atteindre faisons vraiment  et faites en
sorte que les choses qui semblent difficiles soient un
peu plus faciles